تجميد العام الدراسي في السودان شبح يطارد
الطلاب رغم المحاولات المستمره بين وزارتي
التربيه والتعليم والماليه
في الثامن من يناير الماضي اعلن الاف
المعلمين بالمدارس الحكوميه بالسودان
توقفهم عن مهامهم التعليميه بالمدارس حتى
تنفذ مطالبهم وابرزها زياده اجور المعلمين
التي لا تغطي تكاليف المعيشيه موضحين
بدراسه اجرتها اللجنه ان اكثر من 250 الف
معلم بالسودان يعيشون تحت خط الفقر
زياده اجور المعلمين قضيه ليست جديده
وزياده الرواتب شرط وضعته اللجنه لتواصل
عامها الدراسي الذي فقد اكثر من 30% من
المده المتفق عليها عالميا من حقهم يشوفوا
الرواتب بتاعتهم تزيد حسب الاحتياجات
بتاعتهم والوضع العام بتاع البلد الحاجه
الثانيه برضو ما يضربوا لانه هيضيعوا
اجيال جايه يعني والتعليم هو الاساسي يعني
نحن تاخرنا في التعليم شديد ودايرين نتقدم
لكن لازم الحياه مع اشياء صعبه والاساس
المفروض يرتبوا لهم طلباتهم المعقول يعني
والمعلمنا من حقه والله لو حتى الراتب
اللي ياخده هذا يعني راتب اضعاف الراتب
اللي ياخده الحين
في الوقت
الذي يصل حكوميه يؤثروا على الخطط
الدراسيه وربما يؤدي الى تجميد العام
الدراسي حاله استمراره فيما يحذر اخرون من
خطر التسرب المدرسي لصباح العربيه الريان
الظاهر الخرطوم